vamos a resolver ahora el problema 141
141 este problema está muy largo lo voy
a ir leyendo y apuntando cosas sale dice
en la cuenta de la tarjeta de crédito de
anna el balance diario promedio para un
ciclo de facturación de 30 días es el
promedio de los balances diarios al
final de cada uno de los 30 días o sea
por aquí tenemos un ciclo de facturación
de 30 días y entonces tenemos que sumar
todos los balances diarios y dividir
entre 30 para calcular el balance diario
promedio va bueno luego dice al inicio
de cierto ciclo de facturación la cuenta
de la tarjeta de crédito de anna tenía
un balance de 600 pesos un balance de
600 600 pesos va luego dice anna hizo un
pago de 300 pesos a la tarjeta durante
el ciclo de facturación entonces aquí en
algún momento ana paga 300
a paga 300 y entonces el saldo se va a
300 a 300 pero todavía no sabemos cuándo
hizo el pago vale bueno luego dice si no
hubo otras cantidades aumentadas o
pagadas a la cuenta durante el ciclo de
facturación cuál fue el balance diario
promedio en la cuenta de anna para este
ciclo de facturación muy bien entonces
sabemos que en total el ciclo de
facturación tiene 30 días 30 días
ahora no sabemos cuándo han apago estos
300 pesos pero imaginemos que durante x
días durante x días el saldo fue de 600
y entonces durante los 30 - x días
restantes
30 - x días restantes el saldo fue de
300 bueno si tenemos esto así es fácil
determinar o encontrar una expresión
para el balance diario promedio como
durante x días fue 600 entonces le
pondríamos 600 x
y luego a eso le tendríamos que sumar
300 x 30 menos x la cantidad de días que
estuvo en 300 y eso lo tendríamos que
dividir entre 30 vale otra vez esta
parte viene de los días que el balance
estuvo en 600 esta parte viene de los
días que el balance estuvo en 300 y hay
que dividir entre 30 para sacar el
promedio muy bien entonces me parece que
esta expresión nos puede ayudar a
entender mucho más el problema que esta
redacción súper larga ahora sí vamos a
los incisos de información la pregunta
es ésta
inciso de información 1 en el inciso de
información 1 nos dice que el pago de
anna fue hecho durante el día 21 del
ciclo de facturación entonces se hizo el
pago en el día 21 el saldo al final del
día 21 ya va a ser 300 entonces x es
igual a 20
x es igual a 20 y con esta información
por supuesto que podemos determinar esta
expresión verdad si nos dan el valor de
x simplemente lo sustituimos 600 por 20
más 300 por 30 menos 20 o sea 10
dividido entre 30 y esto ya nos daría el
balance diario promedio vale entonces
este inciso si nos permite responder la
pregunta y en el inciso 2 nos dicen que
el balance diario promedio hasta el día
25 esto está interesante el balance
diario promedio hasta el día 25 del
ciclo de facturación fue 540 entonces
queremos una expresión similar pero para
el día 25 para el día 25
25 entonces x días el balance sería de
600 y 25 25 menos x días el balance
sería de 300 de modo que nos están
diciendo que 540 es igual a 600 por x
600 por x + más 300
por 25 25 - x y esto habría que
dividirlo entre 25 muy bien y estoy aquí
es una vez más una ecuación lineal en x
de aquí lo que podemos hacer es es
despejar para obtener x entonces
despejar
x despejar x y ya teniendo x la podemos
mandar para allá arriba para calcular
cuál es el balance diario promedio
entonces este de aquí también sirve para
determinar el balance diario promedio de
la cuenta de anna en este ciclo de
facturación la respuesta sería d
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 142
problemas 142 en el problema 142 nos
dicen que x es un entero x es entero
entero y lo que tenemos que determinar
es si 9 a la x + 9 a la menos x es igual
a b 9 a la x + 9 a la menos x es igual a
b
muy bien a ver en el inciso 1 dice que 3
a la x + 3 a la menos x 3 a la x + 3 a
la menos x es igual
además 2 es igual a b más 2 a raíz de ve
más 2 dice raíz debe más 2 bueno
pues a ver tenemos una raíz a lo mejor
es buena idea elevar al cuadrado de
ambos lados a ver qué sucede si elevamos
al cuadrado esto es un binomio al
cuadrado nos quedaría 3 a la 2x esto es
3 al x al cuadrado más 2 veces el
producto de 3 a la equis por 3 a la
menos x 3 al x por 3 a la menos x es
simplemente uno por leyes de los
exponentes que da 3 a la x - x que es 3
a la 0 y cualquier cosa a la 0 salvo
quizá 0 es 0 es 1 perdón entonces nos
quedaría 2 por 1
más el segundo al cuadrado tres a la
menos 2x muy bien y eso de ahí es igual
es igual a b2 a ver dos por uno es dos
entonces tenemos dos de este lado y dos
de este lado podemos cancelar los y nos
quedaría que 3 esto lo puedo reescribir
así 3 a la 2 x estrés al cuadrado
elevado a la x más 3 al cuadrado elevado
a la menos x igual a de ib3 al cuadrado
es 9 nos quedaría 9 a la x más otra vez
99 a la menos x igual a b
y eso de ahí es justo lo que queremos es
justo la pregunta que nos están haciendo
entonces está este inciso de aquí si
permite responder la pregunta si permite
responderla muy bien y lo que dice el
inciso 2 es lo siguiente el inciso 2
dice que x es mayor que 0
es igual a b esto está muy raro bueno a
ver x mayor que 0 que es igual a b me
imagino que se refieren a que x es mayor
que 0 y 0 es igual a b bueno pues vamos
a ver que nos están diciendo bs esta
expresión de acá entonces nos están
diciendo que ve es igual a 9 a la x + 9
a la menos x que es igual a 0
o sea nos están diciendo que 9 a la x
voy a restar menos 9 a la x de ambos
lados 9 a la x es igual a 9 a menos 9 a
la menos x para se esté restando por
este de ambos lados pues
ok y aquí que podría ser a ver déjame
multiplicar por menos 9 a la equis de
ambos lados menos 9 a la equis entonces
haciendo esta multiplicación tenemos
tenemos menos nueve a la dos equis es
igual a menos con menos es más 9 a la
menos x con 9 a la equis es igual a 1
entonces menos 9 a la 2x es igual a 1 y
que tiene que pasar para que menos un
número sea igual a 1 eso es posible yo
creo que esto de aquí no es posible
menos 9 a la 2x es igual a 1 claro que
no porque 9 a la 2x esto de acá siempre
es positivo positivo
saleh de hecho es 9 a la equis elevado
al cuadrado y un cuadrado siempre es
positivo pero aquí tenemos un menos un
signo menos entonces el lado izquierdo
siempre es negativo y queremos que sea
igual a 1 entonces es imposible que b
sea igual a 9 a la x + 9 a la menos x
porque llegaríamos a que 1 es un número
negativo entonces esta condición de aquí
que está un poco extraña y ni siquiera
usamos esto bueno esta condición nos
dice que es imposible que es imposible
que b sea igual a 9 a la x + 9 a la
menos x porque entonces sucedería esto
de acá sabiendo que b es igual a cero
entonces la respuesta sería y la
respuesta sería a porque únicamente el
inciso 1 únicamente el inciso 1 nos
permite concluir que esta igualdad es
cierta vale creo que bueno no sé si
estoy haciendo algo raro déjame revisar
con calma este problema y en el
siguiente vídeo empezamos platicando un
poco acerca de esto vale bueno entonces
mientras dejamos que la respuesta es ah
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo